بين بناء العقارات او شراءها جاهزه يدخل
المستثمرون الافراد في حيره من امرهم
عمليه بناء منزل جديد ليس امرا سهلا او
اقل تكلفه كما يعتقد البعض الامر يزيد
تعقيدا كلما زاد الاهتمام بالتفاصيل
الشيطان بالفعل هنا تظهر المفاضله بين
البناء او
شراء عليه بين الرايين سنتعرف اليوم على
تفاصيل كل منهما وطريقه التعامل مع فكره
البناء او شراء العقار مع الزميله سمر
المشطه ونصائح في عالم العقارات اهلا
وسهلا صباح الخير صباح الخير
اني قايمه من وجعه توني مخلصه البيت سويت
رينوبيشن فكانت شي جدا متعب قبل ما نحكي
عن او يعني الاستثمار في البيت اللي احنا
بنملكه اصلا خلينا نحكي عن امتلاك البيت
بالدرجه الاولى نشتريه ولا نعمره انو اكثر
اقتصاديه
جميع الظروف يعني نفس المنطقه هنا بيت من
مطور عقاري وبصفى اني دابني بيت على نفس
اللعنه نفس المنطقه نفس الشروط نفس
المواصفات عنيده ابني بالتاكيد شراء البيت
من مطور عقاري ارخص ارخص لانه هو طبعا
يشتري المواد بالكميات كبيره فهو اصلا
ارخص عليه بعدين هو يشتري المواد بعقود
قديمه فاذا صار فلاكتويشن او تغير بالسعر
وخصوصا هسه ويا المسائل عندنا التضخم
عندنا الحرب كان عندنا كورونا دفع سعرها
وبعدين البناء البيت في مشكله اللي هو
دائما المقاول يعطيك فتره معينه وهي هاي
الفتره تدبليها يقول لك شهرين حياخذ اربع
شهور يقول لك سنه حياخذ سنتين يقول لك
دائما الفتره حتكون اطول وايضا الميزانيه
على الاقل
كما يقال
يعني انه اشتري افضل مما انت هذا سؤال
يدفعني الى
لقيت بيت بيت ولكن يحتاج ترميم يحتاج
تهيئه من جديد اخذه ولا اخذ بيت ثاني على
شو نسوي ندخل على
العبس او تطبيقات اللي تبيع هذه البيوت
نشوف ايش قد صارت الطفره السعريه بهذا
المنزل بمنطقه معينه منزل اكس ايش قد صارت
به طفرات سعريه مقابل منزل بمنطقه واي ايش
قد صارت بطفرات سعريه المنطقه اللي بيها
طفرات سعريه اكبر هذا يسوى انه تسوين بيره
لانه حيضيف على سعر البيت وبعدين تقدرين
تبيعيه مره اخرى يعني ترميم مثل ما قلنا
وتجديد ترميم البيت دائما بيزيد من سعره
لما بدك تيجي تبيعيه يعني اذا كان المنطقه
فيها طفران اكبر ومطلوبه بس في مناطق
معينه انت حتحطين فلوس على الفاضي هوفر
طبعا اذا تريدين تاجري لهذا البيت اللي في
منطقه معينه اللي تكلمنا عليه اكس بالاول
ممكن تسوين بعض الاشياء البسيطه مثلا
تضبطين شويه الحمامات
تسوينج للمطبخ بدل ما تفلشي مره اخرى
اليوم في تقنيه الركب الرابينغ
جديد ممكن تغيرين الارضيه يعني ممكن مبلغ
30,000 دولار يحسن لك من مستوى الايجار بس
ما في داعي تسوي اكستنشن يعني
شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك سمر الماستا زميلتنا
والصحفيه في قسم الاقتصاد شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات